ايش صار ايش صار معكم قصفوا دار الشيخ
عيد الطفله
حفيدته هذه طفله خرجت من تحت الانقاض كما
تشاهدون من منطقه
الصفطاوي شمال حي الشيخ رضوان الاحتلال
يستهدف منزل جديد ومجزره جديده في حي
الصفطاوي شمال حي الشيخ
رضوان كما تشاهدون هذا الطفل ينزف على هذه
العربه يبحثون عن مكان لعلاجه به يا عم
[موسيقى]
يا هنا العلاج الاول يتلقونه بمبادره من
اهالي الحي لعدم وجود اي مكان للعلاج
بهين يا عم الحمدله على سلامتكم كويسين
نحله
جات
[موسيقى]
يعني هنا يعالج المواطنين في هذه المنطقه
على يد ممرض من اهالي من اهالي هذا
الحي
[موسيقى]
كويسين لا الحمد لله
كويسين والله قاعدين امنين احنا فجاه انا
وزوجتي واولادي وعندي نازحين حماتي وابنها
واولاده وبنتي واولادها وقاعدين بامان
الله لا في مقاومين ولا سمعنا اي شي ولا
اي فوضه فجاه سمعنا جيراننا ولا هو هواي
بدون سابق انذار ضربوا المبنى نزل دمر
المباني اللي حواليه زي ما انتم شايفين هي
بيتي انا ما تم لا شباك ولا باب حديد ولا
غيره تفاجانا والحمد لله احنا بنقول الحمد
لله رب العالمين الحمد
لله
اينك
[موسيقى]
نج اهالي هذا المنزل باعجوبه بعد ان ضرب
الصاروخ الجهه اليمنى في المنزل بينما
كانوا يجلسون في هذه الجهه اليسرى كانت
فقط اصابات اصابه حرجه وعدد من الاصابات
المتوسطه في هذا
المكان ايش اللي صار بالضبط مع قاعدين في
الدار ما لقينا صو الهواي صار وتصوب ل
الحمد لله رب امنين قاعدين في بيوتكم
قاعدين امنين في الدار عادي يعني ماش فيها
شي قاعدين في الدار
يعني